hey everybody welcome to the couch I am
Dave jewett joined by as always tamaki
say hello Lucy James I am I've dragged
these guys to play a little game called
ultimate chicken horse which trembling I
could I can explain it but I think the
best way to explain it is to play it
okay but basically it's a platformer
where you build your own levels and
awesome Mario maker sounds messy as you
expect it so think we should start with
rooftops to start cuz I think because
it's a flat level it's got the best I'm
a raccoon show off the best so start of
each match we get spy box we choose our
platform starts out very basic just get
some get some get some wood hmm and our
goal is to just go from start to finish
but the twist is is if the level is too
easy and we all get there nobody gets no
points levels too hard wow that one so
we get points now because Tom failed but
if if everyone dies no points if ever
gets there no points the idea is to make
the level hard enough for everyone else
but easy enough for you yeah we should
say as well I'm the Sheep to mazda
raccoon Lucy's the chicken with a mohawk
obviously obviously spirit animal uh-huh
don't owe you scrubs damn a little scrub
chicken see the thing I find weird is a
lot of the like the graphics look very
similar slightly washed out colors so
like as I'm moving and focusing on other
things in my trajectory I lose track of
stock just got to get good time you guys
go with that we've already a bow oh my
god I've already evolved from basic what
was that basic wooden blocks yeah oh I
fell off I mean I'm fine but nothing guy
is shooting hockey pucks at me we played
this yesterday and yeah but the
difference that the parallels between
this is a warm-up yes
okay I need to get real kuantan going
reacquaintance reacquainted with the
flowy jumps and the weird Ronnie is very
flesh gotta go reacquainted with I gotta
get rid of coining but this games
actually been out for a while but I i
I'd never heard of it it wasn't until I
was watching one of my favorite
youtubers play with his powers ice
thinking hey this would be pretty fun
with with my pals oh I've just just one
on the ultimate sheet that was the
warm-up manly ultimately I repeat that's
add an extra page I got so many points
where I repeatedly fail on purpose to
show that Holly as a Welsh man that's
that's my goal in life that's your dream
I love it just means we've got time for
X Ron so let's choose a different level
and you guys vote for whatever level you
want except for Dan spike I vote for the
iguana I'm a chameleon that's not no
that's not level this is a character
let's go I'm gonna go for fun i'm gonna
go for peer Jesus time get your own the
world hey all right oh I fell off oops
the one job was to stand on a bun and
failed where all the magic I tired
that's my season stickin to it that's
why secret kept I'm always telling he
said sounds pretty good don't fall in
the Thresher all right just some legit
props shoulder bones can rotate blocks
okay this is where we start yeah not
very big so she said yeah because ask
who this level isn't huge it means the
traps get real dense blossom dense traps
we chose me I did as well but Chewy's
eat no point so i can make a hard all
right it's no problem okay
please hmm that we deal with that we do
that spring pageant maverick was tired
oh that was a mess Esther stardoll
strong oh yes raccoon on the board nice
what I suppose I can see this level
getting real messy soon put one leg down
man what is this might be done oh
alright something firing good yeah that
was my uh I'm lucky I really weird dream
that's not about all to a chicken horse
yeah looks for some reason um the guy
Larry from curb your enthusiasms playing
on my chicken also walk yeah it sounds
pretty great it was great I'm a crossbow
so bombs will blow up any traps are
existing it was great except poor thank
you listen to me no you tell that bullet
for me I got my own bullet I don't share
bullets and every time he lost he was
like really la you play the music yeah
every time of us are blue great I'll get
his boxing this honey the honey man as
we need the honey matter in one yeah
look look at that look this trap now oh
let's squish I like how we all go of it
walk in with this Oh God oh well I was a
sheep oh my god Wow your body just got
no good you do deliberately just be
bounced up into the end get shot in my
ass over and over again stop he's
already dead okay one more
me don't we all funnies delicious oh god
I'm I've just ruined it don't block my
mechanism blowing this up hey listen
right I may have ruined it first oh my
god what David no we're good we're good
we gucci no look okay I'm good I'm good
I'm good and good I can I can save this
I can salvage this no okay MLG oh my
party okay I've got an idea i'm gonna
wait for this rotating right out all
right he's gonna wall bounce up yeah
you're gonna get shot in the ass oh my
god sign me up for ultimate chicken
Hawks yes chickens on the board honey
looks like chickens back on the menu
boys nice was actually me just Lacey's
okay oh um why would you do this to us
oh just glue something they go well
great oh my god yeah actually can't do
anything about it I thought you just
need to run into the store now or hold
be to give up stop down yeah look at my
cute little Crouch look at that time the
real winner here look at our corpses ham
what the hell oh how close can I get to
this song without getting back no oh
yeah I come in right get rid of times
but we bagged a bombs now otherwise were
stuck in this pit of hell this is like I
have bumps for this
I want to go shopping squat sighs mom's
side there we go oh god oh oh and then I
just stood there I didn't realize there
sir oh why are we having so much trouble
with that one little Bowl thing my body
my bones okay all right I need to start
really channeling the raccoon in me
we're gonna start silly dude is Nene I'm
where's any garbage around 8i can go
through first just gonna put a door here
for no reason whatsoever why oh wow oh
oh oh my hahaha oh who is without them
yes I did it my raccoon state of mine is
paying off I raccoon state of mind ever
Rick I'm you're not heard noises
excellent in raccoon still I don't think
I'm gonna win this funnily Oh got that
greed coin if you get both coins and you
get any of the oh you mean I'm a raccoon
how can I not taken any okay and we go a
high-risk coin the coins are best when
they're and they're not easier yet I put
my wife on the earth sorry the door oh
oh oh oh ok I can get that one down
either sweet each other Oh stupid dancer
she yeah who's the jumps are now really
flowy tell you it's still me from the
ultimate evo all right I need to get
games race as well hahaha i soloed
assault I pick your next level scrubs
listen David Davis you and your sheep
I'm a big fan Oh Pierre
my pyramid so no scrub I like the
Egyptians oh yeah come on sorry that you
guys love to hear em go fire hydrant so
great about to spray some water in your
faces in yo where you go that is what
bizarre place to put that we did more
some bizarre place for them no I run
don't record losses of all these a sea
of the show you're not gonna make this
jump now oops no I fire hydrants I'm
fine I'm fine yeah look at me Noel
laughs right I find him drag oh haha
that's why when it's like having it full
day I didn't flare clean up my bum hole
as well like a Japanese toilet [ __ ]
bumhole you will never get this place
the handbell come on place it what the
hey yeah I didn't want the crossword to
go first
I knew you would deem yourself why can't
I do that John a lot of frustrated Lisa
gets played on too ridiculous don't like
it when I'm not good at things sheep is
gonna feel awful for us are there
because right now that's gonna retain
that water make it bit more risky that
risk reward times putting a trap door to
nowhere no no kept on to my heart oh yes
yes yes yeah oh no no longer suffer no
that was me oh there's no there no Mr
Bond expect you today in the search is
is to harvest upon I thought I was the
nella bomb I just picked up a flower of
some reason to put on the wars it grows
nice and strong great tom this executive
bomb place in there what Tom no I don't
know for fast enough to make a job it's
still screwed I can't get buzzed and
Warfighter soaking this looks in the
except hey finished like one huh don't I
just tell my love it I'm gonna meeting
could make it really risky don't do this
that's that might be too risky because
it is obviously in post it is possible
to make the level my
try it I think I wanna leave we lied out
for you hidden what damn it what that
lying on that platform know if you if
you line up your own property can go up
between the saw blade and yeah honey
someone remove that platform it's not
fair you remove if you what isn't great
combo you see Thanks don't work I'll
just make it hard to the ice yes oh yes
ha see it's what your team just got to
do the perfect jump oh yeah great oh joy
that thank God I was close there though
the fire hydrant is possible it's a
plausible strung believe I'm blowing all
kinds of [ __ ] up by the way you guys are
blowing am I gonna be good to that
blocking stuff I do that what's
happening oh good that's silly luck
oh my I made it I made it pistolet I did
why I'm panicking oh I can see the merit
of this I don't like it oh I've coiner
everything you sick coin points yes
reckon gets coin hi slowing this work
putting an impossible location yeah look
at that a mobile prosper oh ah why is
conceived of that huh you took all the
traps there on the way oh it's that
flower when it swings to punch me a
panic I like how that was there was it
you boys enjoying yep my flower
notorious over there are you trying to
blow up what I just placed that that's
brand new car oh no don't jump oh [ __ ]
oh no oh wait still still own oh-ho-ho
anyway still oh don't do it three times
left this isn't going well you took my
own to leave for me thank you Sam was
that you never get any time to do that
[ __ ] forgot by the wave gotta by the way
ah dr. dre's be sad forgot about a wave
no no the surfboard raised me into the
crossbow no get aside you trade me
oh so thought you're gonna get other
border that this game is making me so
angry by automatically a nice game Lee
so mad that's going to leave the wave
yeah sure or not no listen would you
delete the high listening what is sorry
SUSE calm down something really tough
time right now just stress no scum what
how did you survive but you can do that
in turn around oh look at raccoon look
at this [ __ ] blocking off of there
Marvin finally great underdog [ __ ] wins
skipper respects why'd you get the
teleporter ain't nothing to teleport
here son blue what would you glue there
what indeed no huh camera I'm up I'm up
right don't panic the sound openers 00
include myself I glued myself nope
nailed it oh I'm on the board right at
the end I realize I'm so stressed oh you
got a coin of wine I adrenaline levels
Oh through the roof i can feel my heart
as you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna go
into the sayings real quick and turn up
the levels so you can get some really
messed up levels that's let Lucy pick
the last level then give a give the best
shot gave her all the help I spoke got
me I know it's been a very great mm you
quickly see Oh actually iceberg was the
one that I got ultimately funds all
right stuff my chicken won't win so much
to deliver change the name of time don't
forget
tireless it's my thinking noise is your
home I have a lot of nuances enjoy your
trip on the Titanic this morning's that
would catch anyone out yeah no I'm
literally all watched you put it oh yeah
we another price bunch sir all right
raccoon in front too easy no points muah
hmm what's dude she wake up sheeple
stairway to heaven no oh oh I like a
time down there oh I need some we get it
I'm slipping your sheep if he's a frog
well what are frogs they all know no mom
Elmo yeah all right time it's doing that
I'm game incredibly you guys doing those
weird wheels I don't know I'm putting
them down see what happens he's actually
told OH we went backwards oh dear like
to go forwards so in fact life yeah yeah
yeah
oh no oh what's just gonna cruise on to
the flag cut out of town Bucky sorry mr.
my earpiece out Lynn rage yeah peace
we're gonna clue we're gonna glue you
some good livin
Lucy why they no glue there watch out
for the trapdoor trapdoor to glue oh we
all go to our quarrel in my own bar so
there no one is no point there's just so
many moving parts he confused me dad
have a fear mmm punches brown magic
flower trick well now mrs. we owe you
got encountering oh I was rooting for
you there for a moment Lucy for a
fleeting moment every for a brief brief
big time ah was your biggest fan and I
just pick up all those items what why
don't I get to pick up an eye on
isolated the bomb you did you blew
something up I put up the items what I
know what's going on anymore yeah I
thought this game was nice warm ahead in
a ways that I do not appreciate Oh much
Dave no come grab bank no no it's not a
place here in Reverse okay oh what a
mess though this is um no I think I know
where this is getting gnarly now radical
don't block me on my own couch this is
not your couch it isn't I'm in the
middle of it look see it blew the items
off not how yet it's it's displaying
what the item does oh I've not played
this before properly time we let you
better use it I said properly
the likely story don't worry that I for
my trap door I to my torrents corn the
propellers like that one guy in Titanic
like that one guy do you remember the
guy that got caught on the propeller ooh
ah that's too tired I'd like we lived
though time Joli Joli slowly jump in
here Dom Joly Dom Joly I reckon says I'm
also going to stick to though need more
glue so I've got a strategy yeah I can
see the cowering behind the ship strap
it oh that's okay oh my days yes what
raccoon the crossbow ball just hit me
right in the taint she's taken are you
son of a gun I misplace their my time
can't win yet it's not loud mm-hmm you
see this is your shot I'm Cameron we'll
see hmm no again my sheep taint oh it's
my great let me serve those in friends
she the director delicate doesn't dug
the ticket that's the negative Alex
Duffy delicate taxi delicacy right
you're free just hard reset I'm just a
man a nanny at lunch today we're
flushing the RAM on earth I think you
need to flush the ram your [ __ ] you
just flushed my brain lens brain Rams
huh this is scary Oh all of this is
about area come on is this your time hey
my body my body is number chicken holes
I like a happy my raccoon is all right I
just need to get rid of that oh to be
honest if someone doesn't something with
you I'm just gonna stop myself stop stop
huh in life no Jesus is special what's
the door dearest opens opens and closes
can't blow me last night damn it wasted
a bomb you don't understand yeah we'll
be waiting for you I'm one step ahead of
the game listen II this is why I had
that dream about Larry hey Damon which
tree Valerie are we playing this and
then we went secondly my joke you told
us about what before but ya know knows
I'm reading your blog you have many
dreams with Ari Lucy Lucy hey put the
glue on the bottom of the spinning blade
Nana up up right on the bottom of it
rotate with the right bumper yeah yeah
yeah there this is gonna be weird
don't want this oh really god I gotta go
why Lucy this is your time don't [ __ ] it
up Neely to right in the eyes the mouth
mmm oh you know what my neck is so long
that if I lean back is actually kind of
painful to exert the force hey in my
neck bring my head back up thanks for
that yes now you know how ostrich's feel
I feel like you know when giraffes
winter s what I'm a driver and they hate
each other with it what where am I you
[ __ ] dead scrub why would Jerry why
why give it to the boy tell opposed go
cool down I went through a first do you
love us it was good i do you want to use
a teleport Owens trying I didn't know
that raccoon doesn't take the easy way
out there's a man you break that's gonna
be real weird do it again no oh my my
dog what don't know Dave where are you
Oh No well this is awkward mm-hmm I'm
still gonna take there like a little tie
is like no my rating tie I've been after
me vibrator iconos going in when I gotta
see this this is gonna be good come and
rock and you can do old is gonna be good
oh [ __ ]
Oh God Oh Michael you have failed oh
that was close though yay easy way out
cheers yay I didn't mean dude that's
right yes oh we're at turn aah raccoon
always wins look at me sweet look at the
hips move the hips don't lie raccoons a
winner salsa that is shakira's look I
got a date how many each of us one oh
yeah I don't know but is only one animal
dancing and it's a raccoon you're
talking about where she go did you press
what I guess all right while we all hold
Y to dance thank you so much for
watching hope you enjoyed if you did
make sure hit the like button and
subscribe to gamespot for more dancing
respect your routines